Dr. Jordan Peterson.
Good morning.
Thank you so much for coming in.
You're,
you're developing this enormous power
and reach you.
Is it the heavy burden for it?
Well,
it,
it's heavy and light at the same time.
You know,
it's,
it's constant.
I generally don't know what I'm doing
day to day until that day.
And I have people managing my schedule
and I'm busy enough so that I pretty
much attend to the next thing.
But the responsibility of getting into
all these heads and you are influencing
people significantly,
aren't you?
Well,
I guess I take solace in the fact that
so many thousands of people now have
written to me and also talk to me to say
that things are better for them because
they've been trying to do some of the
things that I suggest in my lectures.
And so it is a heavy responsibility
when,
when you have influence of that sort,
but it lightens it when you also have
evidence suggesting that it seems to be
doing people a lot of good,
you're changing lives.
Uh,
that seems to be the case.
So I been lost.
Well,
I would say there were six people in the
audience last night I was talking in
Melbourne.
I would say there were six,
maybe there were more,
but there were at least six,
so half a dozen.
And they were young men who told me
that.
That that's,
that's what they said.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How do you feel about that?
Okay.
Breaks me up.
Why haven't said it's a very positive
thing you've done what?
What do you mean that breaks you up?
Okay.
Well,
it's sad that there's so many people in
that
state of crisis,
you know,
and they don't need
that much encouragement.
That's the thing.
So it's sad that it only takes that much
encouragement to make that much
difference.
There's a lot of lost people in the
world,
so it's a good thing to be able to help
that.
It's overwhelming.
What can tell that you're very emotional
about it?
Yeah.
Well it's really something,
you know what table?
I hadn't thought much about what had
happened last night,
but you know,
I probably 500 people lined up after the
talk and most of them say the same
thing.
You know,
about a quarter of them say,
look,
you're putting into words things I
already knew.
I always knew,
but I didn't know how to say.
Just like,
well,
that's what archetipal stories do.
And I guess that's what articulate
people do,
you know?
So that's a good thing.
But then the other three quarters of
them say some variant of,
of,
you know,
my life has been turned around.
They say I was addicted or I was
drinking too much,
or I wasn't moving ahead in my
relationship with my girlfriend,
I wasn't getting along with my family.
I didn't have any direction in life.
I was nihilistic or hopeless or anxious
or any number of variants of those.
And I've been trying to put into
practice what you've been talking about
in your youtube lectures and podcasts
and,
and it's really helped my turn my life
around.
Thank you.
I'm just like,
yeah,
give you something.
You feel Fred John about that?
Well,
no,
I wouldn't say exactly that.
I seem to be able to handle this.
It's been going on a long time now.
It's,
it's been 18 months and I would say in
many ways now it's better than it was
because at the beginning,
especially when I got,
when I put my hat in the political ring
let's say,
because I felt that the Canadian
politicians had overstepped their
boundaries.
Um,
you know,
my job was threatened and quite severely
and I thought I might lose my clinical
license as well.
And um,
things were up in the air and a big way.
Those are a lot more gender.
I was my refusal,
my stated refusal to abide by the,
by the requirement that,
that I modify my language in a certain
manner that I felt was inappropriate.
Oh,
it felt it was inappropriate of the
government to demand that I modify my
language.
The government has no right to intrude
on people's lives to that degree.
It's very,
very dangerous when that happens.
And so anyways,
there was,
I've been in one scandal after another
in Canada,
like seriously,
like nonstop for 18 months.
The last one,
just two days ago,
I was at Queens University in Kingston
and there was a big demonstration,
there was a very eerie occurrence.
They arrested a woman who was carrying a
garage for God's sake,
you know,
and that was not good.
The Queen's university thing was not
good.
We were in a hall,
it was kind of like a church that's
hall.
It's what it looked like.
It was lined with stained glass windows
and uh,
probably 20 of them.
And there was a protester had climbed up
in the window,
well of all 20 windows,
probably five or six feet off the
ground.
And they were seven feet high,
these windows and they were pounding on
them and forcefully,
forcefully enough in one case to break
the window.
And so there was 900 of us inside and it
was,
we were surrounded by this group that
were pounding on the windows and yelling
and pounding on the doors.
And um,
it was,
and you know,
you could see against the stained glass,
you could see these shouted,
we forms pounding away.
And it was,
it was very eerie.
No one.
And no one in that hall will ever forget
that experience.
Why would they trying to get in while
the garage?
Why the,
it sounds like height.
He's at height.
Some of it was hate for sure.
What are the hedge?
Because they,
because of who they imagine I might be.
I guess that's part of it.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's easy to hate someone who's been
caricatured and so,
but there's more to it than that.
I have been very forceful,
let's say in my criticisms of the
radical left,
not only in Canada,
but in the West in general,
not critical enough in my estimation.
So I hold no stock whatsoever for the
radical leftists.
I'm absolutely appalled that they are
the force they are in the universities.
And I do believe that in many ways the
universities have done more harm in
society than good over the last 20
years.
And I say that you with a fair bit of
regret because I've been obviously
associated with university since 1993.
It's a really easy thing.
I sometimes enjoy dealing with the
radical lift in universities.
I think you're going to grow up,
you're going to get through this.
And I enjoy the challenge and the drama
and the,
yeah,
it's a challenge of youth saying you're
wrong.
I'm right.
And I know I'm right because I'm 20 and
I know everything.
Well,
it's not the students so much.
I'm concerned about staff.
Is it?
Oh yeah,
it's the staff and the administrators
and no,
it's not the students.
I mean,
look,
I go,
I've been protested against,
I watched the protesters and most of the
time,
the vast majority of them are young
people whose,
whose desire to have a positive
influence in the world is channeled into
this particular political expression at
the moment.
But so many of them are manipulated by
the faculty members and there's no
excuse for that.
And what they're doing is,
is far more dangerous than it looks.
Why do young men need you?
Well,
first of all,
you know,
it's not,
I would say it's not just young men.
Part of that's an artifact of the fact
that most of the people who watch
youtube,
our young men,
um,
but,
but I,
I won't evade the question.
I mean,
because see to some degree,
maturation among men is voluntary
process.
It's not so voluntary for women.
They have to grow up fast.
They have a lot of things to do before
they hit 30.
Yeah.
With men it can,
it can take longer.
And they need a call to adventure,
let's say.
And they need to call to responsibility
and they need to be,
they need to,
to be initiated into responsibility and
to have a case made for its utility.
And so I'm saying,
look,
it's better to be adult than to be a
child.
It's better.
It's better to be in control of your own
destiny.
There's a place for you in the world.
The world would be lesser if you don't
take your place in it,
that you have a responsibility to bear,
to sort out your education,
to straighten out your life and to
become who you are.
Grow the hell up,
grow up and,
and,
and for,
for reasons that are positive for you,
positive for your family,
positive for everyone.
So he's buddies,
this generation lost [inaudible]
desperate.
They,
they're clinging to what you're saying
and doing in a desperate,
I'm not criticizing what you're saying
or doing but they need it.
They need it desperately.
Why?
I think that I think that every
generation needs a message that,
that that supports maturation and
responsibility.
I think that we've done a bad job as a
culture of putting that message forward.
So to me since the mid 1960s our young
people have been fed a never ending diet
of rights and impulsive freedoms,
something like that.
And that leaves a hole because most of
the meaning that people,
people managing their lives and so that
would be the meaning that you can offset
against the tragedy of life that comes
from adopting responsibility and,
and carrying a load.
Like human beings in some sense are
designed for a load and the heavier the
load better.
It's,
it's one of the things that gives you
this,
this proclivity among psychologists to
attempt to facilitate self esteem,
which is a word I don't care much for.
I think that self respect is a much
better term.
I think you develop self respect by
carrying a responsibility.
I,
I feel very lucky to have been born in
this linked to essentially a decent
country.
Uh,
does follow a lot of what happens in the
United States and I get to that in a
moment,
but I was talking to some welfare
workers,
police,
salvation army yesterday signed to me,
they think society is becoming an end,
particularly the younger the age group,
which hawking is becoming more
aggressive,
more cynical,
more angry.
You agree with that?
And if so,
why?
Well,
I don't think the statistics bear that
out because what we've seen overall over
the last,
especially the last 20 years is a
remarkable decline in violent crime.
I do think that there might be an
epidemic more of aimlessness and,
and,
and depression and anxiety,
that sort of thing.
And I think that that's partly because
the case for growing up is not made
well.
And,
and,
and because we're also so cynical about
our own societies,
you know,
I was in Amsterdam month ago talking to
a group of well placed intellectuals.
They are all friends of Theo van Gogh
who was,
who was killed in,
in,
in Amsterdam about 15 years ago.
It was stabbed and there said that
embarrassment about the Dutch culture is
rampant in their society.
I that just makes my jaw drop cause I go
to Holland and I think,
my God,
this is such an amazing place.
These people,
they scrape this country out of the
bottom of the ocean.
They built dikes to hold back the waves.
It's,
it's free.
it's liberal,
it's,
it's compassionate,
it's orderly,
it's beautiful embarrassed.
They're embarrassed by it because of its
tyrannical,
patriarchal nature.
It's like,
well who are you comparing it to?
It's like what are we comparing our
societies to?
Where do you want to live it on,
on,
on the planet or in time,
anywhere,
but in the west,
not if you have any sense.
You've been,
you've sort of been described as a
warrior against political correctness.
Is that fit?
Yeah.
Tell me about this.
And our national carrier,
Quantas got some attention earlier this
week and I was thinking about this.
I knew you were coming in and that they
were taking advice from a diversity
group that that's a bad idea,
bad idea.
And I wanted to ban words like guys and
chairman,
husband and wife,
um,
replaceable replace words like mankind
and chairman.
What's your reaction to that?
I think that it would be better if
people tried to solve some real problems
instead of playing these idiot diversity
games.
I think that everyone who plays identity
politics,
whether they play it on the right or the
left,
is going to pay for it in ways they can
hardly imagine.
It's a very counterproductive way of
dividing up the world.
It's an,
it's impossible to come to a peaceful
solution in the identity politics
universe.
Even the identity politics types
themselves,
they've run into this problem they call
intersectionality,
right?
So,
okay,
so you classify people by race and by
sex,
let's say.
So,
and,
and seek for equity along those
dimensions.
But then,
well,
what about the intersection between
those dimensions?
So you,
you have enough,
uh,
um,
ethnic minorities in your,
in your organization.
Let's say you match by population,
which is a foolish way of doing it.
But you do that and maybe you're matched
by sex,
but then what,
what about the intersection between race
and sex?
Well,
and then what about the intersection
between race,
sex,
ethnicity?
Then you could add social class to that.
Then you could add social proclivity.
Then you could add attractiveness.
There's never ending way of dividing
people up into groups and you can't
equalize across all those ways.
It's just technically not possible.
Do you think people need to a stand on
issues like this and when an airline,
like quantas makes these decisions,
do they need to stand against it?
Do they need to boy clothes,
I need to do that sort of thing?
I think they need to understand it at a
deeper level.
It's like we have to decide if we're
going to divide people up.
If we think that dividing people up
primarily by the group identity is a
good idea and it's not,
it's a bad idea.
It will lead to,
uh,
an enhancement of our tribal
proclivities.
And I don't think that if you're a,
an advocate of peace that you would push
and advocate for our further division
into tribal entities.
It's a,
it's not wise,
is this transit.
When we move through this,
we'll see.
It's been not transient in the past.
It's caused tremendous troubles in the
past.
This is another reason why I'm not a fan
of the radical leftists.
So the,
the radical left ideologies were,
were murderous in their expression
throughout the 20th century.
I mentioned earlier,
this country follows a lot of the US
trends,
good and bad.
We're a little bit behind,
but it can be fashion.
Well,
what do we need to be alert to?
What do we need to be aware of?
What we need to avoid?
We need to,
we need to be alert to the benefits of
the societies that we now inhabit.
We need to be grateful for their
existence and,
and note very carefully the unlikelihood
of their continued success.
Now,
I don't understand how we managed it in
the West.
We have societies where the default
assumption between human beings is
trust.
I do not understand how we manage that
because there's so many ways that you
can be betrayed by someone,
especially if you don't know them.
How do you set up a society where the
typical interaction between strangers is
straight?
Oh,
how many societies in the world are like
that?
Like 30 40 something like that?
How did that ever happen?
We don't know.
And it's an ongoing miracle and we
should do everything we can not to
disrupt it because the alternative to
that generous trust,
that courageous trust,
which is unbelievably productive,
is ruled by thug.
And that's the rule in most of the
world.
So do you have optimism or not for the
future?
I think we're in a time of extreme
chaos.
Things could go unbelievably well if we
were careful.
There's so many good things going on in
the world right now.
They're almost miraculous.
So,
for example,
between the year 2000 and 2012 the level
of absolute poverty in the world was cut
by 50% that was the fastest rate of
improvement by a large margin in human
history.
It was three years faster than the most
optimistic projections had suggested.
There's hundreds of thousands of people
a week now being being pulled into the
electrical power grid.
Almost everyone has access to almost
infinite computational power and all the
educational resources that go along with
that.
We're wiping out most transmissible
diseases.
The fastest growing economies in the
world are in sub Saharan Africa.
Like there are a lot of things.
There's no starvation in China.
There's a huge middle class in China and
India.
These things are absolutely miraculous.
So,
and God only knows what we could
accomplish if we got our act together in
the next 20 years.
I,
you know,
the sky's the limit.
So,
but we're playing very foolish games in
the west and we could bring the house
down around us.
So we'll see.
Thank you so much for coming in.
Good luck with a burden.
Oh,
thanks very much for the invitation and
for the interview,
Jordan B.
Peterson,
12 rules,
falafel,
and added to chaos.